Wow very nice you know I was really
excited and thrilled and very much
looking forward to the occasion until I
see a guy pretending to be fat and naked
running here we can't get anyone to
really do it and then I said to myself
well the executive talent at GE really
hasn't changed much
I've been fired now I love what you've
done with the place by the way I chose
these colors myself it's very strange
for me to to be here I was actually here
a couple of about six weeks ago we were
shooting some silly video tape outside
of the building and it was about nine
o'clock in the evening and people said
well let's go on upstairs to the sixth
floor where you used to work and take a
look around and so we came up in here
and it was just like it was now except
you folks weren't here well most of you
were here and and then we you know
looked around looked at the commissary
looked at the nightly news said and then
we left and then two days later in the
newspaper was an article that we had
broken in pushed our way past the guard
and I had gone up to Bryant Gumbel's
office and taken a nap
what more heinous a stunt could a man
who sees me I'm sleeping on this couch
boys
cover me I'm taking a nap you like it
though you really like what we don't
look good yeah the thing it doesn't look
good and the thing that I liked about it
when I came in here I was in the studio
since 1981 we did a morning show you did
the morning show here right and and it
was comforting to me to see that you
guys have carved out a completely new
identity for yourselves and when I
watched the show it was funny when I
first watched the show it was a little
difficult for me because they say late
night and I think hey team I'll be on
yeah and then then it would be Conan
O'Brien Late Night with Conan and I'd
say to myself and this is how stupid I
am I would say to myself oh geez I wish
I had a show
[Applause]
that's my life
and then as I would watch it and the
truth of it is when I first started
watching a short I'd always kind of made
me wince a little bit because I thought
well I don't know you know it's not
really me it's not my show but the more
I watched the show I realized you guys
do an incredible amount of comedy and
and stuff that is produced that is a
very high level and and the volume and
the quality of the stuff just knocks me
out and I think you've really done a
great job to carve out a a wonderful
identity for yourselves and there's
nothing like the show anywhere on
television and and I really really
appreciate that I think you did a nice
job
I would say the you realize the first
that was before I saw the naked guy in
my say no I know I'm sorry I really am
I'd say the biggest drawback we've had
so far is that you had a very you had a
very funny window we had a very funny
window and and my window
it isn't very funny yeah really look at
this please do me a favor came from a
show like that where there were crickets
and wind blowing on tonight's show I
spent the fruit you know you talk about
screwing things up I'm 46 I've been in
television since 1969 you would think
that the simple things would be under
control tonight for the first 10 minutes
of my show we went down to Times Square
with a live camera and there's a guy in
a patrol booth a little safety the size
of a phone booth and so we were gonna
talk to this guy and he comes out of the
booth and he introduces himself to me
and for the first 10 minutes of the show
I called the guy Lou that's fine the
guy's name is Ray Lewis funnier than I
defended naked that would have been good
come on show me how it's done anyone
right there
and when we were done here tonight I'm
gonna take a nap on your couch but
nobody can stop me completely
unstoppable III want to ask you
something this is a question that people
wouldn't expect but when I first got
this job I came here to 30 rock I mean
did you get this job
so that was with a theme writing contest
yes yes was what would I do with the
talk show and I was fourth
but I went up I went up and III we shot
a remote in one of your offices in it
was actually in your office on the 14th
floor yeah you had moved out and I
noticed on the windows of your office
thick sheets of Plexiglas we're covering
all the windows protective covering and
I thought what a sick man no what is
that what was that all about well first
of all let me correct you it's not
Plexiglas it's a product made by GE and
it's it's half-inch lexan it's it's
bulletproof glass
it's what they use around hockey arena
so guys can't bust through and shatter
glass okay and it's funny when when that
was put up there the guys who did the
work I know they thought I was nuts like
you know he's a guy you snipers oh yes
snipers are after Letterman I've got to
get the bulletproof glass in place
Letterman thinks there's snipers but we
we had been in that office for 10 or 11
years and many of the staff members at
the time and people who are still with
us would come up there and we would do
stuff we would heave stuff around and we
would take batting practice we would
play soccer we would play football we
would play baseball and and one day
during during batting practice hey
that's why the show used to be as good
as it was I was you know taking full
cuts
uh-huh and I swung around and lost
control of the bat and it shot right
through one of the windows now we were
on the 14th floor above the intersection
of 51st and 6th Avenue yes and so the
bat just wedges in the glass and is
teetering on the ledge and so I thought
now this is a sign maybe you kids better
quit screwing around in the office but I
didn't learn anything from that in a
couple of years later a woman who works
with us now by the name of Mary Connolly
and we would come in it and we would
play baseball we would heave the
baseball back and forth just loosen up
and she and I would kind of heat him in
there you know kind of duck him under
your chin and you know see who would
flinch it is this music I'm pretty tough
when it comes to playing ball with the
gals
hey I'll come to your house and take a
nap on your couch that's just the kind
of guts I got is this minutes before a
show should you really be doing
something more that can be said of any
time on my day but this was in the
afternoon and it was like in July early
in July and it was about 2 o'clock and
6th Avenue was just crowded it was just
a mass of people you know going up and
down the street and there at the
intersection and she and I are wing and
balls back and forth and one gets away
from me and I had wound up pretty good
and it goes into the venetian blinds of
the window and shatters the glass and
drops 14 floors to the sidewalk below no
so you think to yourself well you know
folks are dead and it was the single
worst moment of my life in this building
but I summonsed up the courage and I got
the guts up and I said to myself you
know it's it's situations like this
where a person has to be responsible for
their own actions you have to answer for
your behavior you have to know what is
the right thing and you have to do it
and it was then that I sent an intern
down to see who was dead
[Laughter]
very nice well listen we are gonna take
a quick commercial break when you
tolerate that absolutely whatever you
want okay we're gonna step away for one
second make a lot of money for NBC and
then we're gonna come back with David
Letterman sir a lot of people were
watching the Olympics this week then
we're watching your show you sent your
mom to the Olympics which I was does she
have the bug now does she want to keep
going you know first of all that was
that was an actress well my name is
Silvia Henderson and she's great and mom
did audition but wasn't wasn't right
yeah it's it's very strange because a
mom may be the least demonstrative
person I've ever been around
she's very shy very soft-spoken when she
speaks very soft-spoken and we just
decided to send her over there and we
didn't really understand what was going
to happen then it turned out to be
fairly nice but as far as continuing
this sort of thing is I don't think
she's going to Bosnia to cover the
trouble there are other are other
networks vying for her time for her
attention
any chance we'll be on the 12:30 slide
well I guess anybody can get a show at
12:30
I doff my cap I drop it to you I really
would but it was uh you know I my fears
is that here's a woman who is my mother
so you figure she got to be older than I
am you know God if we were roughly the
same age and it's a little yeah he's
she's 73 years old and I thought oh my
goodness and people are over there
fallen down and busting their legs and
stuff and I just thought oh I just the
worst thing that could happen you know
forget the press if I if she gets killed
over there that would just be ugly you
know that would put put an end to the
whole thing right there and I I just had
visions of like a bobsled going haywire
oh there's Dave's mom standing a little
too close because of the credentials
Dave got for his mom she was able to
look right over the bobsled rail and
caught one in the head and but she had a
great time and and the last couple of
days I don't know maybe was the last
week she was rooming with the Italian
bobsled team so I thought I had a girl
mom did you did you ever think all those
years was 11 years you ever think of
using her on the on the late-night show
here we occasionally mom would call on
the phone and we would chat with her
about various things we had her one
night to call up and as a as a kid she
used to make these fried bologna
sandwiches and because we were in about
our second or third year and completely
out of ideas we decided it would be fun
to have mom call in and on the phone she
would talk me through making a fried
bologna sandwich and so I was one of
those deals where I was so excited
because as a kid I remember nothing
being quite so flavorful as this fried
bologna sandwich and I remembered it as
being a lot more elaborate than the
sandwich mom did for us on the air that
night I thought it was like fried the
Bologna and a little butter and then and
then you put like mayonnaise and then
you put lettuce and then you put tomato
and then you put mustard and I thought
maybe this you know this is you ain't
like Elvis
and so mom gets on the phone and she
kind of takes us through it and she says
are all right David now now fry the
baloney
okay now put it on a slice of bread all
right now put on another slice of bread
and I said okay yeah now now what mom
and then she says enjoy my only regret
was that you you didn't use her on that
old show because then your mother would
be the intellectual property user for
all kinds of things just a thought that
occurred to me I I remember a couple of
years ago this is I remember how many
years ago it was but well pick a number
nobody cares all right I think that's
what I do I just make stuff up all the
time it was 1952 name is Ray I called
him Lou nobody cares
no one's keeping tracks that was your
sense all right I remember that you did
something with Carson where Carson stole
your car yeah this is something it at
the time I couldn't tell how much of
this is fact how much of it is fiction
can you straighten absolutely well from
what you've said so far it's all true
Johnny Carson and I I used to live in in
a part of Malibu it's called Point Dume
and it's just this beautiful little
neighborhood and it kind of juts out
into the Pacific now Johnny Carson lived
in the $8,000,000 side of town and and I
lived in about the hundred thousand
dollar site uh-huh uh-huh and I had in
those days and still do a 19-3 a 1973
Chevy pickup truck and the thing that I
loved about this truck was it was just
beat to hell there's like a thousand
dents and because of the sea air all of
these dents would rust and it really got
to be quite an eyesore but the uglier
had got the more pride I had in having
this pickup truck parked outside of my
house so one day I was a guest on
Johnny's show you remember Johnny also
babe
and I'm 14 years old this is a clip-on
tie and I saw hey you know I'm won The
Tonight Show at telling my little
stories and trying to get laughs and
dropping my pants and whatever you get
together and so Johnny I can tell it
doesn't really he's not paying attention
to anything I say I can see in his eyes
that he's waiting to pull the pin on a
grenade he can hardly wait to give this
moment and so finally I wrap up my
little skits my little song and dance
and I'm looking around and Johnny says
uh she tell me about that piece of junk
you got parked out front of your house
you know I don't know and you play along
with cars especially in those days not
so much now but in those days between
you and me Conine pretty much right well
yes
so Carson is whining about my truck
being an eyesore and he says I have to
run by there every day and it's making
me sick and I said I don't know what
you're getting to he turns around they
have like a drum roller so they open up
the curtains and they're in the studio
is my pickup truck and he has swiped it
and brought it in to Burbank and it's
sitting there and it just then serving
as a huge embarrassment to me in front
of the entire world so finally he
returns the truck and I get to looking
it over and I realized that the left red
headlight is busted out so I think to
myself oh man oh I'm salivating lawsuit
that's so about six weeks later Johnny
and I with the aid of judge Wapner I
kind of filed suit against Carson for
the damage suffered by my to my pickup
truck and the judge Wapner comes on and
Johnny and I did you do this on the show
no we did it in his backyard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so judge Wapner is sitting there in
Kherson her behind podiums and it's just
like the People's Court and and and I at
the beginning of it I walked over to
Wapner and gave him a box of steaks I
thought that was pretty slick and
finally I was able to prove and I felt
very proud of this that my truck had
been damaged when Carson swiped it and I
won a $30 settlement from Johnny Carson
I am am Telling I felt a little bit like
one of his ex-wives I was in heaven
he did on that gravy train did all those
years when you were doing the show when
you were doing the show here at
late-night and then you've you've since
gone on to to CBS did you think that
this was all going to get this much
attention did you think that the whole
thing was going to get this kind of it's
just we don't have a lot of time left
and I was just curious did you think
that this was gonna happen that
late-night would turn into because I'm
relatively new to what I had no idea
that it was that important to the media
or to people in general yeah
I had no idea that it was that important
and NBC had no idea that it was that
important
I'm gonna be a squeegee and car windows
tomorrow but you know it's it's easy to
be flip about it and but the derivatives
I love being here and I still have
nothing but really strong positive
memories and the the people that I dealt
with and the executives and the
programmers and the folks that we saw on
a daily basis I I felt like we had nice
good strong relationships and I and I
don't hold any grudges and and I don't
regret anything that has happened but I
am surprised that it did get to be as
sylia as it was you know I mean it's
just but I don't know that's where
things go well listen your tradition
you're supposed to end on a big laugh I
thought what I do is just thank you very
much for coming we are out of time but
this meant a lot to us to have you
stopped by it was a it was very nice of
you to come by and do that this is it
goes on for about nine more minutes
though anyway thanks very much I was
thinking about this Conan all weekend
and this by the way was my worst fear
about the show
I should have I should have brought the
long socks but you know what see look at
that is what how big we busy look at
that I find it attractive it's a good
luck but you know when we did our last
show here and I was kind of wrapping
things up it was really a quiet hope of
mine that that I would be invited to
come back on on your show and I didn't
know if you would would do it or not I
didn't know what the format would be I
didn't know if you'd have any place for
me it was all country music for a while
and then then we got into this which
seems to work I used to I used to be
able to go and see Carson on The Tonight
Show you know two or three times a year
and I loved it mm-hmm and I realized
that for one reason or another I
probably wasn't going back to the
Tonight Show
sergej Avion so to be able to come here
and I hope you'll be nice enough to
invite me back it's been great fun and I
think you guys do a terrific job thank
you I know you have to go to the MSG for
the ESPYs which is a tongue twister now
you have to leave oh it's a big night
for me and my socks but listen thanks
that thanks again do come back and visit
us and
[Applause]